But let's continue talking about.
Statistics of the high level now. How was statistics related
to probability Theory?
How are these two disciplines related to each other? So we
did say that statistics is a science of making inferences.
And we said that inference can mean two things extracting relationships
from data.
Or making forecasts Based on data, but we
need to talk about where the data even comes from. Now. Let's
talk about two key terms population at sample when we
say population. We are referring to the entirety.
Of some things now these things could refer
to a collection of people in a country
for example the population of Canada.
Or it could be the entirety of an animal species all the assets held
by a particular Holdings company.
Or even all the stars in our galaxy so population
can be anything.
But it specifically refers to the entirety of those kinds of
things.
Now for us to make inferences that is to say to
extract your relationships.
Or make forecasts on this population.
Is to look at these numerical quantities we call parameters.
parameters include things like
mean
median and mode. Those are what we call measures of central tendency.
variance
the square root of which gives us standard deviation
skewness
and other such numerical quantities, which as I said
are referred to as parameters.
Now to find out what these parameters are.
So we can describe.
different qualities about the population
we depend on a subset of this population, which is
called the sample.
In fact, we draw data from the
population.
And this data that we draw from the population.
We use two further make inferences about the population. So
this relationship goes two ways. Like it's
super set the population the sample two
has numerical quantities the same numerical quantities
that the population has
mean median mode variance
standard deviation skewness
And all the others except when
it comes to the sample, we no longer use the word parameters.
We use the words statistic and this is where the name
of this subject comes from. So to
make inferences about the population.
And specifically it's parameters.
We use the statistics of the
sample.
Now it's important for you to know.
that we are going to look at a number of
formulas at a mathematical expressions
and these mathematical formulas and expressions will come
in different forms, depending on whether we
are talking about the population or the
sample because the mathematical Expressions will
look different.